I want to do something quite a bit
different than probably every other talk
here and probably the majority of the
talks you've ever been to before rather
than focus on what I think you should do
or rather than focus on teaching you new
technology or explaining something I'm
gonna do the opposite I'm going to tell
you everything that you should not do
and I'm going to tell you this story
based on a lesson from personal
experience based on something that I did
that I worked with the team on and we
got a lot right don't get me wrong but
we got a lot a lot wrong and I want to
share you today this story of what we
got wrong how we fixed it what we
learned and hopefully a couple takeaways
on how to prevent you making those same
style mistakes
so this journey is going to be assisted
by my cute little puppy at a Douglas
she's gonna be in some of the interludes
but really I want to take you on the
background around what the team was what
the technological and business problems
that we were trying to solve for the
architecture involved what we chose why
we chose what we chose how we actually
got this platform up and running from
the local deaf environment getting it
into production dealing with the changes
that eventually came from product and
from bugs bugs and things like that the
refactoring we needed to do and kind of
finish it off with some of the lessons
that we learned to give you some
background when I joined the team it was
nine developers they had just recently
grown from five developers in the path
in the year before hand the original
five were there for about four years
beforehand and built the entire
monolithic application that existed and
so we grew to 23 by the time this story
starts we went from five to nine in
about a year and then 9 to 23 in about
nine months
recently closing around a funding of
aggressive growth and so we had a decent
sized team the team had a fair
bit of experience range everything from
quite junior to some of the most senior
in the industry that we could find very
very experienced developers about half
the team was PHP focused a couple of
those people had experience with golang
and Scala etc we had a number of
front-end engineers mostly focused on
JavaScript react was the new thing at
the time and we had hired a very very
good react team and built a react team
under us we also had data engineers as
well as dev ops as well as so test
engineers I mean DevOps is kind of a
loaded term operational engineers a
couple people focused on infrastructure
and an SRE to help actually run the
existing platform that we had and so
it's a very new team the team existed
for less than three months as the whole
before we kicked off this project the
background the legacy system so I
mentioned we had a monolithic
application this monolithic application
had bits of Zend framework one
CodeIgniter Symphony cake and a bunch of
PHP for in pair code in it and to be
fair it worked pretty well it powered a
multi multi multi-million dollar a year
business for years but it was kind of a
nightmare to work with
we started doing quite a bit of
refactoring you know as you see symphony
which started to refactor prior to me
coming in to try to condense onto one
framework but it was just such a large
application about half a million lines
of code that that's not an easy thing to
do the biggest problem though is at the
data layer the application as you see
here had about 600 database tables this
is not a complicated application 600
tables for something that you could
probably do in about 40 should give you
an idea of kind of the level of
complexity in here and this thousand
crowns
number that is not an exaggeration I
believe the exact number was like eleven
hundred and fifty or something like that
and the scariest part was the
application was designed over many many
years and so reporting so reporting was
a really important area that we of our
application that we did that we shipped
to our clients and multiple parts of the
application would write to the reporting
area the reporting tables except they
would over it write slightly differently
partially because of bugs partially
because of differences in design over
the years and so the stats were wrong
because the database was updated in a
weird way and so rather than fixing in
common izing and putting a library as
most developers would do the solution
was well let's just install a cron job
to fix this and so we had cron jobs that
ran every five minutes every 20 minutes
every 15 minutes to clean and rectify
the data it brings a whole new
perspective to the term eventually
consistent so this was actually a huge
huge problem and really slowed
everything down working with this system
was a nightmare and so when I joined
when I when I was hired they were just
ending a nine-month product freeze and
what that means is no product work
happened at the company for nine months
they focused purely on refactoring on
moving the infrastructure away from the
dedicated hosts that they were on
beforehand on into AWS on a couple
security things that had to be taken
care of for compliance reasons and on
trying to make the system easier to work
with at the same time sales did not stop
so we had increasingly increasing scale
requirements we had new customers that
were closing with ten times the number
of users as our price bigger customer
biggest customer and the product wasn't
support to scale for that and so we
needed to ship faster we needed to ship
better code we needed to ship products
that were stable and the business was
really demanding and so we kind of hit
this precipice point where we had to
make a decision do we continue trying to
refactor this do we continue trying to
solve the application's problems in the
code base that exists or do we throw
away the existing platform and build a
new one and rewrite it and so the way we
approach this question I think is really
really interesting and so I want to take
a little tangent to kind of go into this
process a little bit because the exactly
answer we got to is quite unexpected
when we face this question we walked
into a room and when I say a room I'm
talking about maybe two meters by 2
meters room with four whiteboard walls
with whiteboards on all four walls we
walked in the head of product head of
design myself and two other engineers
cramped into this tiny little room and
we got out of our whiteboard our pens
and we started listing every core
assumption that we could think of of the
of the product now when I say a core
assumption think of like your users
table when you have a user you probably
have an email address associated with
that user right common email on the user
table you probably have a unique index
on that email address right that's an
assumption you're assuming that an email
is uniquely identifies a user if you
wanted in your application to change
that assumption if you wanted to say I
want to have two users be able to have
the same email address how difficult
would that be for you probably not
terribly difficult yeah you'd have to
change some of your authentication logic
if you're using emails for
authentication you probably have to
change a little bit around like password
resets and account management and stuff
like that but for the most part that
should be a pretty straightforward
refactor in our case about 60% of the
system relied on the fact that emails
were unique some of the reporting pieces
looked at email rather than user ID and
trying to tease that apart and refactor
to use user ID what
been incredibly incredibly difficult so
what we did is we filled all of the
whiteboards with everything that we
could think of that the product assumed
okay that took us probably about three
hours to do and so we filled out all of
this information then we took a
different color marker and turned to two
product brought the rest of the product
managers in and said this assumption
here the email is unique within the
system per user do you want that to
change within the next year and if they
said yes we drew a line through it if
they said no we left it in the colors if
they said now maybe eventually we left
it alone we did this process for every
single one of them and we were left with
three assumptions that we did not want
to change out of four walls worth of
assumptions like we basically wanted to
change everything about the product
without changing it so that led us to
the decision to do neither we don't want
to refactor because that's going to be a
nightmare trying to change everything
about the program I mean even if it was
a really clean application trying to
refactor that much would have been an
insane challenge but we also don't want
to rebuild because rebuilding would mean
rewriting the existing application and
so what we chose was to build a second
product at the highest of high levels it
did the same thing it solved the same
stupidly high level business problem but
at every layer below the way it did it
the approach that it took how it solved
it from the user perspective how it was
administrated how it was maintained the
technology everything else was different
so we basically went to the board we
pitched this let's build the second
product let's invest as much as we can
into this once it's up high enough we
can migrate our existing customers over
and throw away the exists the existing
one and so this is what we did so
everything from this point forward is
going to be talking about that new
product that we decided to build and
this
is literally a greenfield project we
walked in with a team about 23 at the
start about 35 towards towards the end
of what I'm going to talk about here and
so we needed to start off from scratch
and how do you start off from scratch
well there were this new thing this is
in the 2014 era there's this new thing
called search as in 15 new thing called
micro-services which was all the rage
we had experience building one of these
micro services so we sat down and said
what if we built the entire application
off of Iker services what would that
look like and so we started drawing
diagrams and we started building into
the relationship and we started doing
design sprints and we started doing the
events storming and we came up with a
plan for the UI the architecture as well
as the application design this is
actually pretty close to one of the
initial stabs at the architecture that
we took and what we've wound up finally
building at this point actually I should
caveat some details have been changed
from the reality some things I'm going
to exaggerate a little bit for effect
and some things aren't going to be
identical to what we did but it is still
I think in spirit good enough and it's
also some of the things that have been
tweaked or to make the point across
better so if anybody is watching from
the company from the team I hope that
the rest of this aligns so we have this
architecture I think the most
interesting initial part was we went API
first by design so we had a front-end
server in a single page front-end app
actually a series um I think there were
about three front-end apps for different
usages that were based on react so we
had a front-end server that ran node
that rent pre-rendered react and served
it up to the client worked absolutely
phenomenally was really really stable
everything worked great so I'm not going
to talk about the front end at all from
here point but this point forward it was
an amazing part of what we built but
this talk is
about things that we did wrong not
things that we did right and so let's
skip that so the first thing I want to
focus on here is this big green thing in
the center this thing called an API
gateway to put time and perspective here
when we decided to go with this
architecture was exactly one day before
Amazon launched its AWS gateway API
gateway to private beta an hour
AWS representative reached out to us the
day after we made the decision to go to
this route and said hey we have this new
feature that you would you like to be a
private beta member and so we stopped
and we looked at it and we had been
researching other technologies and we
decided not to go with AWS gateway but
that should put the rest of this story
into context because we ran into that
problem a lot where we made decisions
because we had to make a decision and
then very shortly after a better
alternative came up that we should have
probably taken so we went with Tyco
it's a open source tool written in go
lang
he uses MongoDB behind the hood which it
worked phenomenally well but you know
take what you want what you wish with
[ __ ] no offense to anybody
so what Tyco is is a API gateway it
terminates and separates external
requests from internal requests so in
the public domain anything outside of
your firewall hits Tyco Tyco handles
both for you so you're off to
termination all of your secrets all of
your key management is all done by Tyco
nothing in your application needs to
even know about OAuth it's completely
agnostic to it it doesn't have to know
about rate limits it doesn't have to
know about anything to do with security
of the request Tyco terminates
everything publicly and then just simply
adds a header that says I validated that
through other services that this user is
user ID X that they have a valid token
that here's the exploration time of the
token in case you need it
etc etc
and so your application can focus on the
application and doesn't have to worry
about these things
if you use Symphony or Zen or laravel
this is very very similar to the
middleware pattern applied at the
services layer this is a middleware
that's only for public requests for
external requests internally every
service use our PCs and use these custom
headers to identify authentication
information etc which made it really
really easy to iterate the private
servers behind the scene very very fast
we were deploying these servers in
production once we got everything up and
running probably about four or five
times a day in changing API is
potentially as much as often whereas
because of Tyco we were able to keep the
public API the public REST API quite
slow and quite stable phenomenal design
pattern it worked really really well for
us this is one of those type of
decisions that I think that we got
really really right early on and if I
was building a system of this scale
again I would absolutely use a api
gateway of some sort we had fantastic
luck with Tyco and Tyco worked well but
I know there's plenty of other
alternatives so that separates outside
the firewall to inside the firewall and
note that the front end server is
outside the firewall and so that means
nothing about the front end depended
upon anything private about the back end
we were developing against our public
api's so when we released our API to
clients to build off of as a third party
API we knew that it worked because we
had the front end the test of it we knew
it solved the business problems because
we had an active team of developers who
was developing against it and we knew it
solved the use cases completely because
what we built our application off of it
so aside from some like really really
narrow use cases we were pretty
confident in our public API the next set
of layers is the backbone of this thing
the message bus or RabbitMQ as we chose
one of the problems we ran into we used
RabbitMQ as a pseudo event sourcing
database meaning every change to the
application so if you update your
username gets emitted as an event from
the user service that event goes back
into the RabbitMQ other services can
listen to it and adjust their state
effectively and so we had only one set
of shared state which was RabbitMQ I
should note this we chose RabbitMQ
specifically because at the time it had
the best bindings in PHP today if I were
to do this again I would choose Kafka in
a heartbeat just because Kafka gets one
of the biggest issues we ran into with
rabbit it makes Kafka makes non existent
which is ordering of messages rabbit has
the subtle property and it's not subtle
it's actually blurred in big bold
letters but we just kind of ignored it
for some reason
that you can't trust message order and
so we had this archive service that
would take the messages that every
single a message that went on the
rabbitmq and put it into an archive well
when you have unordered messages and you
have an archive of unordered messages
and the messages are changed are changes
to the application what happens if those
messages get reversed yeah that caused
us amen a metric ton of pain and the
biggest reason for that was these
certainties were not directly querying
by any of the applications so we had
this event source database if you will
in this archive but no applications
actually bound to the event store and so
if you study an event sourcing or if
you've gone to any of the talks that's
one of the most critical aspects to
keeping an event source system
consistent and so we got that really
wrong and paid quite a bit of a price
for that but the thing it did allow us
to do
was keep every application complete
every service completely separated every
service had its own caching system had
its own database and was really its own
isolated pod and it used rabbit to
communicate and we communicated in two
different types of methods one is an
event which is kind of those application
changes that I talked about the user
updated their username username change
event comes out and then our PCs we did
quite a bit of work with video and video
transcoding and so one of the common
operations was a user uploads a video we
need to transcode it into a bunch of
different things we need to extract
closed captions etc all of those
processes they all take a lot of time
and so you would send off an RPC request
to RabbitMQ to tell it hey do the
transcoding and then at some point in
the future you would get a response
message back saying the transcoding is
done do the next thing that our PC
system was actually quite reliable and
was a phenomenal use of the platform so
the final layer that we'll spend a good
bit of time talking about today is the
service layer the names here domain
service async service and meta service
or stuff that we came up with to try to
to distinguish the way applications
behaved we had an internal platform that
we used I wouldn't call it a framework I
would call it a set of Composer files
that brought in and wired together
applications differently for each one of
these services so for example async
services need to talk to rabbitmq a lot
and so we had PHP services that were
built on this and so we had a base
package for PHP services that listened
to rabbit pulled it together so they
weren't really framework although some
of them did use open source frameworks
the difference between these are kind of
what purpose they serve inside of the
platform the domain service is named
because it's a domain entity if you've
looked at domain driven design you look
at the different entities you have we
basically took every domain entity and
stuck it in its own service give or take
all communicate over HTTP and they have
their own persistence I mentioned we do
a lot of batch jobs async services they
only communicate over a PRP see the only
HTTP endpoint that they open up is a
health check and then the meta services
kind of fill the gaps between the two
and I'll give you a concrete example of
what that looks like so this is a
simplified version of the domain that we
were working with you have users you
have assignments and a history object
and then lessons with content and with
assets so assets would be video files or
images or anything like that
content has many assets a lesson has
many pieces of content and assignment
has many lessons and then we keep track
of what lessons the user sees not
terribly complex model the reality was a
little bit different but what we did was
we built a service around each one of
these primary entities and so we turned
it into a user service and the simón
service a history service and lesson
service a content service and an asset
service that's a lot of services and
especially when you throw that out to
the rest of the application and the rest
of the design we had probably about 50
services within a year and it was
growing quickly and the demand was quite
high so the question comes let's say you
want to show an assignment on the front
end so the assignment remember has a set
of users that it's associated to has a
set of lessons etc on the front end in
an administrative portal how would you
render that well the naive way would be
to call for the assignment and then loop
over each one of the other objects and
do another call and have you know a
couple hundred thousand HTTP requests
from the front-end in order to render
the page we decided not to do that
rightfully so
we also decided not to go with something
like graph QL to do that for us because
two reasons one we saw the that basic
the graph QL would just shift the
problem to inside of our firewall rather
than outside of our firewall but to and
more importantly the assignment concept
is a concept that in vote that comes
over all of this so when we're shipping
a public API I wanted to show that
concept in that API so we wanted to have
an API that actually returned the domain
information for all of this and so what
we built was a meta service the meta
service knows how to talk to all of
these services but it's also listening
for changes on RabbitMQ so anytime you
update some of one of these things it
updates its local state so requesting
from the front-end only has to hit
there's one service which 99.9% of the
time just fetches things from cache and
pushes out of the cache so it wound up
speeding up the application drastically
and it wound up making it really really
simple to work with from an API layer
the problem comes what if we changed the
question what if instead you want to get
a list of lessons ordered by content
author name I mean naively you would get
every single user get every single
lesson do the join and then order it we
could create a lesson sorting service
meta service but that would be really
weird we could do a whole bunch of other
things but every single solution is
dirty and is weird the actual solution
we eventually deployed was elastic
search so we built a search service that
would do these type of of highly
aggregate queries for you so that's kind
of the infrastructure of what we
designed and started to build so let's
talk about the infrastructure for a bit
at the time there was a project that was
just announced but was not actually
released yet called kubernetes and so we
actually couldn't run kubernetes because
there was no
kubernetes to run and so we started to
look at we knew we wanted to do
containers primarily because we have go
we have PHP we've got Scala
we've got spark
we've got Hadoop that we're all running
in this in this infrastructure so we
wanted some kind of a job worker to
manage all of this
I mentioned spark we had a production
spark infrastructure on the prior
application so we had a good bit of
experience running a product called
Apache mesas Apache may sauce is like
kubernetes but not for containers for
abstract jobs so it's a layer down so
maysa runs on all of the different
servers in hybrid environments so you
can give it servers in multiple
different data centers etc and then you
give it jobs and it figures out how to
run those jobs and handles that for you
and there's also another open source
software called marathon which basically
binds meso s-- into docker so we've ran
marathon on top of meso s-- and we could
have one cluster that ran all of our
data jobs as well as all of our HTTP
jobs and so we wound up having was about
I think it was about forty to fifty
servers that could deploy containers to
and we basically we just had an API so
when I wanted to deploy a new service I
could just call an API and the new
container was spun up I told it I want
four instances meso figures out the rest
we coded in rules that instance if
there's multiple instances of a service
they must ban data centers because again
Mesa is smart it knows about where the
servers are it knows how to orchestrate
everything and so this is kind of what
we had at the network layer we've got a
whole bunch of servers that may Sosa's
is running marathon is orchestrating how
we route networks we used eel because
eel bead Amazon eel bees are insanely
reliable but they're also slow to update
so we used h a proxy which could update
in the span of milliseconds and so we
built this tiered system to be as
reliable yet as performant as possible
and so a request
would come in it would hit the elbe the
EOB would call H a proxy H a proxy would
then call Tyco which is running in a
container just like any other service
and then Tyco would do OAuth it would do
rate limiting it would do all that fun
stuff and it would figure out this is a
call for an internal service so it calls
down to that domain name which then hits
that load balancer which then hits that
H a proxy instance which then calls up
into the service adds maybe 10
milliseconds of latency yet we've tried
to kill it we literally went in and
killed maysa nodes we killed H a proxy
nodes while load balancing it and it was
surprisingly robust internal requests
worked the same way except they skipped
us to skip a step so if a wants to call
a different service it just calls that
service goes through the EOB and comes
back into the service so what this means
is if we want statistics on what's going
on inside of our network we only need to
look at the load balancers the load
balancers will tell us every piece of
communication because no one service can
talk directly to e to another service so
we knew what was going on in the stack
speaking of knowing what's going on in
the stack let's talk about monitoring
and logging we have Mae sews a host
that's running a series of containers
well we're running docker and so we want
to collect the log so we put log spouts
in each host and log spouts pushed off
to a Kafka queue which then pushed off
into data dog NS three logs were
available instantly for every single
service and you didn't have to do a
thing about it it was all automated for
you even which service that came from
was automated we had the docker
container information and the host
information so you could correlate this
we also wanted to collect metrics so we
deployed a stats D collector on every
host so every host is taught every
container is talking to a local deploy
of stats D and so we got our metrics
from our application and finally we
wanted some tracing information and what
that means is if one service calls
another service we
want to know that and we want to be able
to see in debug well this request failed
what was the original request and be
able to trace backwards or this service
is slow so let's see what else why it
was slow what was slow in the in the
query path and so we use something
called Zipkin it was at the time really
difficult to work with because it was
right in the transition period before a
major fork and so the open source
version of Zipkin was difficult to run
and didn't wasn't really stable yet but
the closed source but available package
was also really difficult to run so we
spent a lot of time trying to get
zipping up and running and towards the
end we actually wound up did get it and
getting it up and running I did wind up
working out quite well but that's
something I wish we would have done in
quiter a bit earlier the final piece of
the infrastructure puzzle is the
services that JSON or service that JSON
config file so I mentioned we had like
50 services every service has its own
docker can def sorry github repository
and in the root of that github
repository we defined a service that
JSON file define what the name of the
service was what other services this
depended upon so we knew what to spin up
what type of data stores it needs note
there's no authentication information
because all of that was generated by
deployment so we would automatically
know that you needed a Postgres database
so we'd spin up a Postgres instance
create a database name user table etc
and settle the environment variables
100% automated so humans don't actually
even have access to that information to
find your health checks your service and
type the public endpoints that you had
and the deployment variables and so if
towards the end the goal was if you
wanted to deploy a new service all you
have to do is create this file and then
tell our central deployment system about
that github repo and it did the rest it
deployed it spun up all the instances
every time you push to master it knew
that it needed to rebuild a container it
handled CI for you the goal was really
quite doing everything
so with all of this said this entire
infrastructure section does any of this
look familiar I mentioned at the start
there was this new project called
kubernetes that was that came out in the
beginning right when we were starting
this program but wasn't actually open
source yet it was just announced this is
basically kubernetes we built in large
part of kubernetes and a large part of
the architecture decisions we made by
luck by knowledge of the team etc wound
up being almost identical to the way
kubernetes actually runs and so all of
this stuff that idea showed you that we
designed built and worked on we could
have thrown away and just replaced with
one spin up today at the top point in
time again we were just a little bit too
early to use to use kubernetes but today
just use kubernetes and forget about
that it doesn't mean you don't need an
ops team it doesn't mean you don't need
automation it just means the the
infrastructure is handled for you and
you need to maintain that piece so let's
talk about local dev I mentioned we
kicked off this whole process we had a
three month window where we were looking
to build the Minimum Viable Product so
we built the first I think it was about
ten services built the infrastructure
got everything up and running and spent
the last month of that three months
trying to get it running in production
and what we realized was that's going to
be a nightmare we knew that's going to
be a nightmare so let's try to make a
local Devon spirit experience that's
going to mimic what we're expecting in
production what we intended what we
actually did build build was a
command-line tool that you would run so
you would check out that repository
you'd run this command line tool it
would look for the service definition
and it would figure out well I need to
spin up a database I need to spin up the
dependent services etc and so it
basically generated a docker compose
file and then ran docker compose up and
just spun up everything locally it
always designed to work friction
it was designed that every time you spun
up these services it would run your
migrations for you so when you had other
services that you depended upon that
we're moving quickly they stayed up to
date their databases stayed up to date
the data in them stayed up to date etc
and it was all designed to wire
everything together the same way we
wanted to wire together fraud and what
actually happened was that was not used
every developer ran their own service
natively they ran Apache or nginx on
their local machine PHP fpm built the
service if they needed to talk to
another service nine times out of ten
they just like kind of faked it and made
their own little endpoints that they
could call or mocked out that portion of
the application so that they didn't call
the other services they never ran
sometimes they would actually spin up
the service they depended upon on their
local machine they would talk to the dev
of that other service and say help me
get this thing up and running and what
happened was they got stale so service a
depended upon service B so I get it up
and running on my machine today next
week when I go to ship my service I'm
depending on an old version so old that
when I tried to deploy I need to go fix
all of those inconsistencies between the
two it was a nightmare it was an
absolute nightmare
so we started we stopped and we thought
about well why why is no one using the
the local dev system and it turns out
there were a couple key reasons it was
excruciatingly least-loved spinning up
because it had to configure sometimes up
to like five to ten other containers and
other services and build them all
including database containers and
everything the spin up time was about 15
minutes
from the time that you said give me a
new dev environment to the time that
your new dev environment is ready to
work about 15 minutes my codes compiling
yeah it was difficult to use it
frequently broke or frequently got into
inconsistent states that you had to
manually just kill it all and rebuild it
and it's just kind of really just
unreliable but that's not why it wasn't
used it wasn't you
used because it was someone else's
problem a person on the team was picked
to build the local dev experience and to
maintain that local Devon's experience
and they did that but all the rest of
the devs were told to just use this
thing but were never given any ownership
over it so they never had any investment
to fix any of the problems when
something went wrong well I got to get
my work done so hey you go fix the
problem I'm gonna go work over here
locally and so it just never got
adoption because it was always someone
else's problem that's I think the
biggest mistake from the infrastructure
side and from the ops side that we made
was not making local dev every single
developers problem making it someone
else's tool that they maintained really
really bit us hard and so trying to get
this thing up and running was quite a
bit of fun and quite a bit of a
challenge I mentioned we we got the
first set of services up in two months
out of that three month window getting
the first word production request took
another month think about that we're
code complete everything works locally
getting it up and running in a
production infrastructure took 30 days
ouch it failed for a whole bunch of
reasons some of which are probably the
text book you're looking at going up yet
but been there been there some of which
were due to the the failures of local
dev and consistent local dev experiences
and some of it was just bad management
on my part and the part of my team where
we built services to idealized behavior
we didn't actually have real mettle to
try this stuff on to learn how it works
so there were some just learning kinks
that we had to get out I mentioned
services were built in isolation but the
biggest problem was we got to code
complete at month two but we still had
more product to build so all of the
production all of the product engineers
were off building new services while
infra was finished finishing and
finalizing the infrastructure and by the
time we ran into problems devs were off
of those services for a week or two and
that context switching back to Oh pi
gotta fix this bug okay nope I've got to
fix that cost us a ludicrous amount of
time and the API is we're evolving
rapidly which led to all sorts of
problems trying to maintain it I'm not
going to read every one of these this is
kind of like a dump of some of the big
takeaways from getting it up and running
in prod take a look at the slides
afterwards or take a picture here the
one I want to really call out is this
guy RabbitMQ events for missing data or
structure so I mentioned we used
RabbitMQ is an event source well what
happens if your event source your chant
all of your changes that the entire
application relies upon or missing data
that's a pretty critical issue the
problem was our services were all tested
incredibly well we had about we had over
a hundred percent coverage I say over a
hundred percent coverage because we had
a hundred percent line coverage but we
actually had very very reviewed unit
tests for every single service the
services were insanely well tested from
a unit test perspective so we tested the
when an HTTP request comes in that it
triggers the change that we expected to
the model to the model layer we tested
that when the model interchange model
layer changes correctly we get the
change persistence the database
correctly we know that when that model
layer changes we get an events that get
submitted to the events to work
correctly with the correct information
all of that was tested but we didn't
test was all of that put together we had
no smoke test that when an HTTP request
came in it did all of those things
together and what happened was we had a
wiring error wherein a couple services
the wiring from the request coming in to
the event going out was just ever so
slightly misconfigured and so the events
were still going out they just had no
data and so user changes we're admitting
events that were empty how do we find
this out well I would love to sit here
and say well we had instrumentation we
had a service that identified this and
our error reporting was great
we found out because we went to try to
replay the events to restore to build up
a new service and we're starting to get
errors building that new service after
about a month of uptime and went Oh crud
this is not good
we lost the production data we did -
managed to resolve that we did rebuild
but it cost us a pretty significant
amount of time the lesson is always
smoke test in addition so I'm not saying
smoke test every path but make sure that
the application is wired together
correctly unit tests are not enough
especially when doing something as
complicated as a distributed system the
final major point that I want to cover
is dealing with change so we have this
thing out in prod we're serving customer
production traffic and product changes
come in could be because we got client
feedback that says the thing that we
built wasn't exactly what we need that
happens that's good we should do that we
should respond to that it partially was
executive stakeholders coming in saying
I want X or e I think we need to do Y
which is fine and natural I don't think
any of those were like egregious or
anything it's just natural course of
product progress and sometimes we just
didn't get it right the first time and
we needed to iterate a couple times a
hundred percent natural change is
natural to software let's take an
example of a real change let's say this
is a hierarchy of data and let's just
say each one of these is a service it
wasn't in our case but let's just do
this for for for example purposes a
program has many topics each topic as
many lessons each lesson has many cards
in each card has many assets
what happens if product asks you to add
in a new layer to this and when I say a
new layer I'm not talking about like
these are categories that are just a
taxonomy like these are each domain
objects with actual business rules built
against them how would you refactor that
in a monolith that's actually probably
pretty easy you just add some of the new
logic and then do a migration and you're
done
what about removing one
that's probably even easier in an in a
monolithic application context but when
you talk about services
how would you refactor this well it's
not easy the refactoring actually was
one of the most difficult parts because
we had to do three stage where factors
stage one was well actually four stages
stage one was figure out what the change
was that we wanted to do so we wanted to
change these four api's and create this
this fifth API we needed to go to every
service that depended upon the one we
wanted to change make it so that that
service could accept either version
either the old version or the new
version deploy all of those make sure
that's up and running stable II then
deploy the new version of the target
service and then finally go back and
clean up and remove all of those
conditional logic stood append to allow
that the old format what would have been
a simple one day change that was just
involved in ETL on your application and
a migration became major major
coordinated surgery that required almost
the entire team that I think was the
biggest failure of the architecture was
it made it really easy to respond to
change the micro-level
it made it nearly impossible to respond
to change at the macro level at the
larger level and so wrapping off only
summarize a couple of the key takeaways
first off I mentioned that we designed
our services really small at the entity
level we didn't appreciate how
unreliable service calls are I mean you
say it out loud and it's yeah we know
HTTP is unreliable but how unreliable is
it let me ask a question how often do
you expect a method call to fail I'm not
saying what the method does I'm saying
the method call itself to not execute
the code in that method one of maybe a
billion requests when I start one in a
billion method calls no there they're
more reliable than that
one in whatever that large number is
incidentally this this large number
actually does have a a root if you look
at Symphony and you take a like a hello
world style or sorry another hello world
a real world Symphony application and
just look at the number of methods it
executes in one request and then
multiply that by 99.999% up time you
wind up getting roughly that number and
so if the reason for a symphony
application failing was a method call
failing and not like HTTP request or
database issue or anything like that you
would get something about that that
method and reliability in practice
though you don't think about it we don't
think about it when we do
object-oriented design when you talk
about solid when you talk about design
patterns every single one of those
things with the exception of like the
proxy design pattern is based on the
fundamental assumption that method calls
are 100% reliable I guarantee you none
of you when writing code ever think
about well what if this code method
doesn't actually enter the code that I'm
going into yet with a service call that
is absolutely going to happen over and
over and over again even if you're able
to do five nines of uptime that's one of
in every 100,000 requests is gonna fail
and so the biggest error that we made
was how big of a service should you make
we went for the domain size because we
were really good at domain design and we
were really good at object-oriented
design and we decided to treat micro
services in a service-oriented
architecture as objects and the reality
is that was a horrible idea and so what
I would have done in what we actually
refactored to at the very very end and
after I had left was this so have a
couple of services where the domain
boundaries are very very narrow and very
very defined and that's it the lesson
service handles everything about lessons
one of the guys on our team coined the
term micro with and use the
Micra lists expression to define this
start your services as micro lists as
large as possible because it is far
easier to split apart a large system
than it is to stitch two dynamic systems
together especially when there's a lot
of dependencies and a lot of network
traversal between them build it large
and then when you need to split or
refactor something out and do that it's
far easier my number one recommendation
do not do micro services in reality
there is a caveat here I'm not
suggesting micro services are a bad
pattern obviously there's lots of very
large teams and very successful teams
who do it very very well but do not do
it period unless you have a dedicated
team to tooling in infrastructure and
I'm not just talking about production
pooling I am talking about developer
tooling if it is not easy for your build
systems to work and for you to run tests
and testing infrastructure and do your
own local dev in a hundred percent
automated fashion you will have a bad
time at scale with this type of a
complexity system I mentioned start with
big services it's easier to split a
large instance and it is stitched
together to automate everything
deployment is the obvious one but I'm
talking far lower than that your spin up
getting a new service into your
infrastructure automate that automated
deployment automate your migration are
you using a migration tool that's
dependent upon your service we're using
one tool for all of your services
automate your backups state restoration
is a huge one if you want to reproduce a
production state locally without
downloading production data how do you
do that how can you set up all of the
objects all the services in the right
state it's actually a pretty difficult
problem don't plan for failure live it
this is the biggest takeaway I mentioned
don't do micro services I still use
serverless architectures and I still use
you serve services and I still would
recommend people using services the
biggest change to how I approach writing
that code is I write the failure case
first so when I have a service that's
going to call a second service the first
thing I write and I test and I deploy is
what happens if that service was missing
how am I going to recover how am I going
to gracefully handle that issue get that
in test it and make sure that solid and
then handle the happy path because if
you focus on the happy path first you're
going to code yourself into a corner and
you're going to have a bad time at some
point in time and the finest one would
the final one which I didn't really
touch too much here is around service
level objectives if you haven't read the
Google SRA book I would highly highly
recommend it it's a phenomenal book but
one of the big things that they focus on
is business service level objectives
what I mean by that is for every service
we tracked a whole bunch of metrics we
tracked time to first buy we tracked
average response time we tracked
requests per second etc but the business
doesn't care about requests per second
to your users table they care about the
number of successful authentications
they care about the ratio of
authentication failures they care about
the number of lessons you're actually
able to deliver they care about all of
these other metrics the technical
metrics are important I'm not saying not
to measure those but think about what is
the business case for this service why
does the business care that this service
exists define those objectives and get
them into code get them in the code
early get them in your monitoring
systems and be sure that your service is
operating to what the business needs of
it not what the geeky technical need the
biggest takeaway that I've got from this
entire experience is what we do as
software engineers or software
developers as programmers on one level
is writing the code to solve a problem
but when you get beyond that I think our
number one job is managing complexity we
can write complexity into our source
code in front of us
the 1998 way of doing things where you
just have a single page spaghetti app
and the complexity of the system is
really really small but there were a
complexity of what you're looking at is
quite high
you can refactor and may use more
object-oriented design where the object
that you're looking at is quite simple
but at the expense of more complicated
code elsewhere you can use modern
frameworks which or
you know there was a controversial post
about visual debt a couple years ago
where just remove all type hints from
your file it makes it look simpler and
it does it makes what you're looking at
simpler it makes that complexity goes
somewhere else in the application and so
that's I think the biggest thing is you
can never eliminate complexity you can
only move it around or edit and so when
you're dealing with change when you're
dealing with systems and applications
and software be cognizant of where the
complexity you're introducing goes and
what trade-offs that you're that you're
exercising with respect to that
complexity had a really good
conversation last night with a couple
people and there was a discussion about
the difference in writing software for a
library that has three million active
users and writing a software for a team
of 12 to maintain fundamentally it's the
same thing we're writing software for
both but the complexity trade-offs are
vastly different you can deal with and
get away with a lot more when you're
dealing with a small team so you have to
understand your audience in the context
with it with it within your running and
the final takeaway is it's far far far
too easy we got bit by this we got the
battle scars for it to create a system
that is so complicated that you cannot
understand it and if you can't
understand it how can you possibly hope
to run it in production to debug it to
maintain it and to keep it alive and
actually work with it quickly thank you
[Applause]
we have a few minutes for questions if
there's any questions in the room did
you ever end up refactoring to take on
some of those technologies you kind of
missed going out of the door so did we
wind up refactoring to check tanks so
things like Kafka things like yeah not
to my knowledge not by the time I had
left the team this is not the team I am
with right now this is a prior a prior
organization by the time I had left no
I've kept in touch with a number of them
I do not believe that they have
refactored in those directions but you
know when you have a system that's up
and running the trade-offs of moving off
of on to those other systems if the
infrastructure was built so the benefit
to moving on to kubernetes would have
been relatively low given that all the
tooling was built and was automated but
yeah some of it we did but most of it no
other back there microphones coming
it'll be there
thank you so about that problem you've
mentioned when you had to go all over in
services in support simultaneously both
versions of the message what do you
think of an idea I think they call it
message translator or something from the
enterprise integration patterns so you
just put version support for your
messages from the very start so if your
current message if your current service
does not support version each as
declines the request and doesn't process
it and so when you refactor your
messages yep you just put an extra
service that duplicates the messages and
translates the new version into an old
one and then you refactor all of your
services one by one and just remove the
message translator after that does that
work yeah so for the message layer for
the event was for rabbitmq we actually
had a different we we had a solution to
that problem where every service was
required to handle all of the versions
of every event because we had that
message store so instead of trying to
upgrade in real time on the fly and only
give the current version of the event we
actually had mandated support for every
event and that was tested so we didn't
run into that problem on the service
layer where we ran into that problem or
sorry I'm the event layer we ran into
the problem was on the HTTP layer with
HTTP service calls and could we have
implemented another service to backwards
translate absolutely and that actually
probably would have been a
halfway-decent solution to that problem
but we focused more on the nimble side
of trying to keep the application up to
date and the type of changes that I'm
talking about most of them are more
business logic changes than just
structural changes so and having a
single proxy turn a and the B would work
for structural changes but I don't know
that would necessarily off-the-cuff work
for the level of business changes that
we had
that we would need I think we have
another like that so you've given us a
river health warning on mic receivers
that's much appreciated what would you
take be then on using that architectural
pattern of a message bus to glue
existing services together and to also
be the glue for new services sa CRM to
talk to instead of direct way to all
these services that CRM has been talking
to go through the message bus instead
and have you got any steer and tips on
that biggest tip is what is your single
source of truth for data is your single
source of truth a API is it that message
bus itself and or is it something else
have a single source of truth for every
piece of data it doesn't have to be the
same one but every piece of data should
have exactly one source of truth and
make sure that that source of truth is
row busted and anytime you need truth go
to that source of truth so if you're
using a message bus to communicate
changes that's perfectly fine like I'm
not saying rabbitmq should not exist or
anything like that for an application
layer absolutely should but how do you
handle a miss message do you have a
mechanism for going back and
reconstructing from a source of truth
that's tested and that's robust that's I
think the biggest piece I would look at
again it's handling the failure case and
so if your source of truth is that bus
then handling that failure case could be
just replay from the bus and so you rely
on the bus to deliver your messages
reliably